(fanfare)
pour la reine que pour
l'ambiance qu'ils sont venus.
Et pour être vus autant
que pour voir.
"C'est de toute beauté,
s'exclame suis
si heureuse d'être ici!"
(cris de joie)
dans les premiers rangs sur
le Mall ont pu voir défiler
200 chevaux et 450 musiciens.
(fanfare)
Mais surtout,
tour à tour, les membres
de la famille roya
C'est vêtus de la tenue
militairheval que
se sont déplacés les héritiers
de la re
William et la princesse Anne.
(cris de la foule)
La duchesse de Cambridge,
Kate, les trois enfants
la duchesse de Cornouailles,
ont quant à eux parcouruarcouruu
le Mall à bord d'un carrosse.
- Oh!
depuis qu'elle est sur le trône,
ciy.
a reçu le salut à la reine.
Cette dernière a quand même
tenu àtenu àtenu àtenu à faire e
apparition surprise au balcon,
accompagnée de son cousin
(fanfare)
70 hélians de règne :
une finale tonitruante
au-dessus de Buckingham Palace.
Entourée des membres de la reie
a offertoule conquise
et sans doute soulagée image
qui vienr
le jubilée de platine.
de la famille étaient invité
au balcon. Ni Harry et Meghan,
aux célébrations,
ni le prince Andrew,
qui, lui, s'est dit atteintnts.
Tout sourire, la reine avait
l'air enchantée du spectacle.
(applaudissements)dire autant
de son arrière-petit-fils Louis,
qui lui a ravi la vedette...
grimaces bien senties.
La fête se poursuit La reine
a beaucoup apprécié la journée,
mais elle a ressenti un certain
malaise, a fait sa
royal en soirée. Elle ne seradoe
religieuse prévue demain.
Radio-Canada, Lon